i want you to meet backer ali he's a new
immigrant from iraq
i fought with him against al qaeda in
iraq shoulder to shoulder
we walked the streets of samara together
planned raids together
and he saved american lives he is and
will always be
my brother he now lives in houston where
he's been the top salesman at an
accurate dealership for months running
now he's in
the home building business smart guy
with all those liberals fleeing to texas
he's a muslim and he and his beautiful
family love
america you should hear them gush about
it
proudly in english he earned his pathway
to america
after three years of fighting the state
department bureaucracy
he earned a visa to this country and
he's made good on it
proud and free
but when joe biden and the democrats
talk about refugees
they're not talking about bachr they
want different
americans which brings me to this
each year the white house notifies
congress of the maximum number of
refugees the executive branch plans to
allow into our country in the coming
year
this number is known as the refugee
ceiling
because there is no glass ceiling the
left doesn't want to shatter right
why not crash that one as well well
yesterday the people in charge of the
white house
whoever that is announced they would
raise the refugee ceiling for next year
to the
highest level in american history
the highest ever to a goal of 125
000 authorized refugees next year
a number higher than has ever been given
in a single year even to say
jews in world war ii germany for
reference that number
125 000 equals the population of say
fargo north dakota or wilmington north
carolina
no big deal right well by the way this
125 000 refugees
is on top of the hundreds of thousands
of illegals flooding our southern border
totally different head counts add them
together
and now you're talking the size of miami
minneapolis
or atlanta every year
today the white house defended the move
he wanted to eliminate any lingering
doubt from any refugee across the
world that the united states wasn't a
country that would welcome
refugees in to apply under the biden
harris administration
oh don't worry jen the message is clear
there is
no doubt america is wide open and we
have no reason to believe the numbers
won't grow even more
because just last month the white house
announced they're considering an
entirely new category of refugees
climate refugees refugees used to have
to be fleeing war or persecution
now they need only be fleeing the
weather
we would be the first country to do so
on the planet to make this designation
well i guess another global ceiling for
us to break
jake sullivan the national security
advisor is now charged with delivering a
report
on the topic in august stay tuned
i smell yet another executive order and
who better to do it than jake
formerly of the yale center for the
study of globalization
but he's not just a globalist yali he
grew up in minneapolis minnesota
more on why that matters in a moment
you see this refugee increase like
everything else biden and company have
done
was a craven cave to the anti-american
open borders left
their base freaked out two weeks ago
when in light of the border crisis that
they wouldn't admit
the white house initially planned to
keep the refugee number
set by the trump administration orange
man
good on the heels of the rise of isis
and the migrant invasion of borderless
europe remember that
president trump put a ban on refugees
from certain countries and sharp cuts to
overall refugee admission
seems sensible to me right america first
but those days are gone so 2020.
common sense once again crushed by sheer
ideology
as we know the white house has gone
full-on globalist not just on borders
and refugees
but even on get this taxes the white
house also just announced they're
seeking a
global minimum tax to pay for their
endless domestic spending
this is council of economic advisors
chair and harvard university lifer
cecilia rouse defending the tax
internationally we don't want to be
disadvantaged so he's also working with
other countries so that we have a
minimum tax internationally
so that there's not a race to the bottom
ah harvard grads they love
fancy phrases like race to the bottom
now when i think of race to the bottom
i think of my minnesota vikings and what
they do every year in the nfc north
okay as a recovering harvard grad by
cell phone harvard man
allow me to translate she means we can't
allow countries to lower their tax rates
to entice business
we all must pay more the global system
will
be fed not to mention the globalist
climate scheme this white house is
obsessed with we all laughed and then we
cried
watching massed up joe biden attempt to
convince
communist china to give up emissions
over a zoom call
maybe he was just trying to show
solidarity with the residents of beijing
who wear masks every day to deal with
smog because well
we're like the world is going to end in
12 years if we don't address climate
change
and your biggest issue is
your your biggest issue is how are we
going to pay for it
and like this is the war this is our
world war
ii like this is world war ii
that was two years ago we now only have
10 years left
enjoy the roaring 20s because the dead
30s
are coming speaking of biden advisors
that brings me back to minneapolis
what does unchecked illegal immigration
and massive waves of refugees
look like without assimilation it looks
like this
globalist joe that's ilhan omar global
joe just
like jake sullivan loves ilhan omar
which underscores why his refugee move
yesterday
is so dangerous ilhan omar was a refugee
she came to america as a young girl
fleeing the civil war in somalia
following four years in a refugee camp
in kenya she was granted asylum to the
united states eventually settling in
minneapolis
she graduated high school there attended
college in north dakota
and secured a prestigious policy
fellowship at the university of
minnesota a few years later she was
elected to the state house and then to
congress
congresswoman omar has chosen to return
american goodwill
with grievance not gratitude you've
heard her
she views her time in somalia as
blissful
while criticizing the united states as
racist oppressive and
torturous that's a direct quote unlike
my good friend bocker ali
ilhan omar did not choose america
america chose her
from the squalor of a refugee camp in
kenya we opened our doors and welcomed
her the state of minnesota housed her
educated her empowered her enriched her
elevated her and then elected her
all so she could make a living out of
condemning america
now she is setting the terms of u.s
refugee policy
inside the halls of 1600 pennsylvania
avenue she
is the authority and she wants more
refugees
just like her moments ago i mentioned
the word assimilation
don't say that word too loud you're not
supposed to say that word
anymore you may have missed it but when
the news came out last week that the
department of homeland security was
banning use of the words like illegal
and
alien for ice in the cbp they also
included ending the use of the word
assimilation
what is this evil idea of assimilation
the left says it's xenophobic but of
course it's not
it's essential new immigrants must seek
to assimilate and pledge allegiance to
the united states of america
assimilation
and allegiance if you want a nation
without those those ingredients we melt
down in our melting pot
and destroy what holds us together our
tribes
our skin color our sexual preferences
and our religious denominations are not
what make us americans
our god-given freedoms equally applied
laws in common english language do
if we don't share values share civics
and share language we soon become
balkanized
and feckless europe now
now that i think about it that might be
what the left actually has in mind
waves of refugees with no duty to
assimilate and worse nothing to
assimilate to
why would you want to assimilate to a
country that is systemically racist
if america is evil and assimilation is
evil then our future is inevitably
anti-american government dependent and
non-english
speaking and if you don't think that
means democrat votes
then i have a bridge to sell you in
mogadishu
what does this all look like well just
five years ago i hit the streets of
minneapolis minnesota for fox and
friends
a neighborhood dubbed little mogadishu
with a majority somali muslim population
this is what we found the islamic
schools in here in minnesota they teach
sharia law yeah sharia law
and what do they teach also american law
the u.s constitution
actually i have no idea about that one
we're here with fox news just doing a
story about the riverside area
no english any any at all no just wanted
to see if i could ask you a couple quick
questions
no english would you be willing to chat
with us no is your language
no english no english this was not the
exception
truth is ilhan omar's minnesota is a
preview of what the white house wants
for a city near you
just look at old europe which already
has it europe decided long ago to open
its borders not demand assimilation or
allegiance from new arrivals and got
their militaries to pay for their
welfare states
it was a perfect recipe for division
dependency and decline
it's what global joe wants here and let
along by ilhan omar and comrade cortez
he's doing it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else